Україна - дев’ята у світі за кількістю
внутрішньо переміщених осіб.
Це понад півтора мільйони вимушених переселенців
з окупованої частини Донбасу та
анексованого Росією Криму.
50 на 50. Сплачуєш половину вартості житла, а іншу
частину бере на себе держава.
Така програма діє в Україні, але скористатися нею
переселенцям донедавна було практично не можливо.
Щоб стати на квартирний облік за новим місцем
проживання, потрібно було знятися з обліку
за попереднім місцем реєстрації.
Отримати відповідну довідку з окупованих територій не можливо.
Наприкінці вересня нарешті це скасували і
спростили інші бюрократичні процедури.
Тож отримати від держави половину вартості житла
стало легше, втім у бюджеті наступного року на всіх
переселенців грошей не вистачить, стверджують експерти.
Ситуація з безробіттям серед переселенців дещо покращилась.
За даними Міжнародної організації з міграції, якщо у
березні минулого року було 35% зайнятих, то
у вересні цього року - вже 49 %.
Найбільше переселенців знайшли роботу в Києві та
в прилеглих до зони АТО областях.
Найбільш проблематично влаштуватися
у малих містах і селах.
Зростає частка довготривалої зайнятості, тобто
довше 12 місяців, а також відповідності
знайденої роботи кваліфікації переселенця.
За опитуваннями, 40 відсотків внутрішніх
переселенців вважають, що коштів їм
вистачає лише на харчування.
Найвищий середній дохід переселенця у Києві -
майже 3 тисячі 300 гривень, а найнижчий - у західній
Україні - трохи більше двох тисяч.
Формально добробут переселенців потроху
покращується, але на практиці на тлі загального
здорожчання життя вони цього не відчувають.
Представники програми розвитку ООН в Україні
нарікають, що в Україні досі немає комплексної
стратегії роботи із внутрішньо переміщеними особами.